that's okay what I want to look at the
footage after though okay no it's a
calcium it into your eyes yeah I've
never seen I've never seen it absurd
yeah Bryce yeah you documented it like
my Rae habit me oh it's on there you had
so you have it on tape it's on the hall
we have to watch it just for ourselves
might help me like I don't want to do
that again don't erase no I know what we
can do so what we can do is we can just
get the video
don't put the audio and then I'll send
it to you just so you can see the
reaction no I want to see the audio I
want to see how it transpired I think
we'll laugh at it
no I mean like I dunno laugh at how
ridiculous it is okay one more thing
before we go guys let's glad that I've
heard about this I've never seen it I've
heard stories but I got to spur in so
thank you it was a tree I've never seen
a clean yeah because what you save could
people meet Steve they go that guy is so
sweet because just right now right now
it isn't basic I'm a scissor I might
yeah it was a treat Gilbert be real yeah
what you saw it happening were you
scared I was trying to think how do I
calm the situation because that's why I
kept going yeah then I saw how he stood
up yeah babe the tables a kalila would
you know I don't remember doing I walked
away I walked away first because I've
seen your red zone before and I don't
like being a part of it and you follow
it's like the document it's like camp
drink it's all have trig the Bigfoot
okay yeah I'm wrong yeah or the Loch
Ness monster like I'm sorry yeah I gotta
see it it's like an urban urban legend
that we caught on camera it's a good one
[ __ ] we're not gonna air that part part
we want to see it don't ever erase it
yeah I want to I want to see that little
chunk of rage yeah your eyes put it see
what happens it's
yeah I started crossing right yeah let
me ask you since it's all said and done
you said that thing when did you guys
realize like oh right away once you said
it I part punching but yeah I realized
that yeah and I said no that's not
because I knew that that was going to be
the reality I saw your eyes my eyes
crossed yeah you went pale first and
then you got red it was like the blood
left your body and then it went right up
oh yeah your I could feel the wheels
turning the wheels turning and I could
see your heart right it was in shambles
yeah I just shatter and then in then you
you know when what Bruce Campbell
numbers Campbell oh man Ernie Hawk
things ripping your shirt was ripping
here's what I knew this which like you
know in the in acting classes they tell
you like and you're doing comedy you're
very expressive and we're like we're
doing drama don't move your face did not
move your eyes no no movement anywhere
your voice got lower and I was like you
matured like 22 you seemed like older
yeah like you were talking it was like
the age shift there's almost it I go it
was scary
oh you know what he also does I've
noticed in San Diego I mean when I we
were in Phoenix when I cook hey I'll go
call tell taco see if they're open yeah
and when he calls people he goes like
this he he changes his voice I don't
know why are you guys still open yeah
okay cool thank you know who you are
what does I know but why does he do that
don't know it's a weird work think times
I have a call in a weird and I make up
call places just to hear it to hear him
excuse me why do you do that it's
[ __ ] crazy yeah yeah it's really
weird you know what I realized tonight I
do need anger management
and I need a bit I have [ __ ] up
oh no no no but it's my reaction I think
I you know I think I need a therapist
would help me because I need to sort out
some things and maybe 2018 the year for
me to
work on myself in that regard you know
like not be so you know quit quit to
react you know to really sit in it and
really and rationally and like a adult
and process I don't like do you think I
want to be like doing this what if I do
that too i Lonnie mm-hmm
now have you've never raised against her
well the times I have a nap she cries
and good she cries right yeah horrible I
mean awful where those that's a yeah I'm
aware we go back and forth rage you go
there I go louder you go louder I go
louder and then there's a point at which
I get too loud that you're like oh [ __ ]
okay yeah I need a back down you're very
calm I can't see you going there
I get very I've been learning if this
this won't be more self-aware being
passive-aggressive because I feel like
that's very that can destroy a
relationship when my instinct is not to
talk something out and just say
something a comment and walk away where
I'm thinking I'm walking away from the
situation but all I'm doing is I'm
adding more to it so it's like a quiet
rage that's some [ __ ] we just like
[ __ ] spit fire and then walk away and
you see you do the hurting and also
acknowledging that I have that okay I
was gonna say it takes a lot for you to
get there that's a lot it can't and not
really that's what you also are Jaz the
most positive person or ever like I
think this is why Gilbert is my balance
and I need him is because when I'm
having the shittiest day he'll come in
and he'll show me his butt and he'll do
a dance and then I'm happy again crisis
like that - yeah bryce is like very calm
he's calm yeah he's very good energy
he's always a real killer you're like yo
you're the gayest non-gay guy I've ever
met well you know I'll take that really
I when I first met you I'm like who was
that [ __ ] comedy the story 20 times
and then it's so weird that you eat
[ __ ] yeah it's so weird
gaius doggy a game yeah alright that was
a good podcast a rocky start
after rocky side no what are your
thoughts on this weird we're still
running you know here's my how we gonna
sort through this I know Jerry Springer
thought we saw an air that I genuinely
think that yes you have some things to
sort out perhaps your age or your
emotions but in this particular instance
your reaction was very proportionate to
what he said meaning I think immediately
when he said it there was a reason why I
punched him six times because I thought
that was wrong to say and I immediately
looked at you and I thought that you
actually played it pretty cool
considering what he said
I only egged you on with my attitude
yeah and that was not everything I did
was right and so the problem was not
because use at that point it's my you
know I'm the you know I had to defend
myself what you did to him was so [ __ ]
up cuz he says hey Bob why did you say
that man that hurts me and then you said
from the hour I thought that too and he
asked you why you said that and then you
said oh my god so what'd I say all of
this like you didn't even acknowledge
that I know that offense mechanism right
there we go us finally on my side
Gilbert let me ask you something now
obviously that's not gonna be in there
but it's gonna cause a question big
question one and let them think you know
it gives it mystery yeah yeah and they
say this hey can we plug some stuff to
podcasts go ahead I wanted us Oman she
is uh you don't mind if I do this no
good that's what you're here
Monty we're doing a festival called the
grizzly fest and monkey is a bad man
it's the band that I'm in and Snoop
Dogg's gonna be there nas at most a gram
but monkey is on the flyer so it's May
eighteenth and nineteenth look up
grizzly fest that Fresno Ray a beautiful
city of Fresno California so it's kind
of like Coachella banana really and
check out not really not really
check out Stevie we be back
calm and Kwangju few a NGO you on
Instagram thank you
what are you a president yes my brother
also has a a podcast oh shoot I got my
own YouTube show the Stevie we be show
huh Brice and what should I tell him
about that I subscribe subscribe to my
channel and check it out Stevie we
beastie bball east yeah Ollie's with
yeah oh he's great guest thank you so
much oh my god that was
[Music]